michael thompson the lakers radio
analyst two-time nba champ
joining us on the program been a while
michael thank you for getting up and
joining us
just a coincidence that uh the lakers
had all those free throws or do you
think this was something that uh was
carried out premeditated
oh no not at all dan and the lakers came
out much more aggressive in game four
than they did in game three
and uh they they were rewarded for that
aggression they were attacking the
basket they were playing physical
and that's the nature of the nba and
guys uh who played and coached in this
league for a long time should understand
that sometimes
the calls are going to go your way some
games sometimes they're going to go
against you
and that's just something you have to
play through when when you're not
getting any calls that's when you got to
buckle down
mentally get mentally tougher and say
okay we're not getting a call tonight we
got to find a way to
win this game as opposed to always
looking at the referee
and hoping to get bailed out and that
goes for the lakers and the nuggets
i don't know if it's just because of the
number of games they played in a uh
you know a finite amount of time in the
bubble but
this is the first time i can remember
seeing lebron
where i i'm i'm seeing an older lebron
he still can be brilliant take over a
game
he knows his role there was a good deal
of time last night where he sort of
faded out and uh you know wasn't a
factor here am i reading too much into
this michael though it has to catch up
with him at some point but
it feels like he almost has to pick his
spots a little more than he ever did
before
sure yeah still he's 35 years of age
actually
19 years into his career dan not 17
because you add in all the playoff games
he's played
played two years of playoff basketball
so that's two extra years so
19 years into his career at 35 and
having got to be the guy to carry a team
every team he's been on that takes a lot
of a large toll on your body and
sure he has to pick his spots at 35
years of age and there's nothing wrong
with that all the great players kobe
michael jordan kareem they all had to do
it at 35 to 40 years of age so and the
good thing about lebron is
he's got the second best player in the
game that he can depend on to carry the
team and anthony davis so
he doesn't have to carry for 40 minutes
like he had to in the past
why can't a.d do this every night
because he's too unselfish he's such a
good uh teammate
that if he demanded 25 shots a night 30
shots a night he put up these kind of
numbers that's how great and unstoppable
he is then but
he knows he has a bunch of other
champions on his team guys who've been
there done that and lebron danny green
javille
javale mcgee uh j.r smith if he gets in
the game the lakers have
six champions royjan ronda they've got
six guys on this team who
won there been there done that one
championships and he knows that
yeah i can go out and be selfish and try
to score 40 every night but those guys
that i have with me they know how to win
too
so he understands that and he allows
those guys to do their thing too
why do we still marvel at playoff rondo
or we seem surprised with playoff rondo
because a lot of people don't understand
all the little things he does to help a
team win a championship he's top-minded
he's a competitor he'll go out and get
the tough rebounds
he's still an excellent passer he knows
how to lead the team he's been doing
that since he was a rookie and boston
and a lot that's a lot of people he
don't he doesn't put up the big numbers
like a steph
or damian lillard or those type of
guards so people overlook him and they
don't understand
all the little things he does to help a
team win championships
he and he never looks like he's having
any fun michael
that's the intense look did michael
jordan look like he was having fun on
kobe when they were out there that's the
intensity
that rondo plays with man i love that
about him
who is the role player that has to play
well for this team to win a title
well that's a great question because the
lakers have so many good ones
from alex caruso to dwight howard to
kyle kuzma
but i i would say if you needed a guy to
step up every night especially to win
the next round
um they're all important but if i had
you made me single out one guy
i guess i would be cool because kuzma
has the ability to come off the bench
and give you 20 points and sort of do
what jeremy grant is doing for denver in
this series kuzma has the ability
to talent the skills to get the lakers
20 points a game or 18 to 20 a game
in the finals once they get there let's
move ahead
let's just say the miami heat and the
lakers face off in the finals
give me like handicap that match up like
what kind of headaches
problems will the heat give the lakers
well that's so well balanced and so well
coached they played tough defense
they spread the ball around there a lot
like denver they moved the ball well
they've got shooters all over the floor
especially now with the emergence of
tyler hero
so they're well-balanced team they have
a well-balanced attack they don't depend
on one guy
to carry them every night it could be
jimmy but one night dragon
uh dr dragon the next dragon's the next
night could be hero the
youngster showing up like this jay
crowder can knock down three so they're
very versatile
uh team that uh this that's the team the
lakers is gonna play
and of course they're well coached in
that pat riley style
he's michael thompson the lakers radio
analyst two-time nba champ of the lakers
plus if you had lebron and he had to go
back to miami
now that would be a juicy story line
because those fans wouldn't be happy to
see them but
the fact that they're going to be in the
bubble you know you're going to
neutralize that
or you're going to take that off the
table so that would be an advantage for
the lakers but then they don't have that
home court advantage so it's
probably evens itself out you feel that
way
that's what makes yeah that's what makes
these playoffs so different this year
dan even though the lakers are up 3-1
you know just because they're not going
back to la for game five
you know things are still up for grabs
because they're playing on a neutral
court sort of a sterile court so
not being in front of your home fans
makes all the difference in the world
and you're right
uh what an atmosphere that would have
been for games three and four in miami
if lebron was coming out there
oh man definitely miss it we can't we
can't have this happen again
were you on the lakers when magic hit
that hook shot in the boston garden
you bet i was i was right there on the
bench had a great view of it i was on
the court with him but
uh right that was like the last of
possession so riley got me out of the
game so i wouldn't mess it up
do you remember what the play was was
was magic supposed to take that shot
no that was kind of like off of a uh he
you were looking inside the kareem
and but then kevin mchale sort of
switched out on magic and magic said
you know what i could take this guy off
the dribble and that's when he can then
get that little running hook across the
lane you know what if magic would have
missed that shot if you look at that
highlight again if he would have missed
that
kareem was right there for the put back
dunk because nobody walked down
blocked our green robert parish and
mikhail went at magic johnson so even if
magic missed we were going to win
because kareem is going to tip it in or
dark it anyway
how crazy was that atmosphere when when
you guys
you know that game ended and then just
trying to get to your locker room
and i remember being in that locker room
and it was so
hot in there no air conditioning it was
so tight
it was just chaos in there what do you
remember about when that
that shot goes in how intense you're
right about how intense that whole scene
was in the boston garden
how cr crazed those fans are how much
they love their celtics and how
the you could cut the atmosphere with a
knife it was so thick the tension was so
thick every minute of the game even in
warm up
you knew that this was just a totally
different from just playing
any kind of a regular game going against
the celtics in boston in the finals with
the laker
nothing in basketball would ever compare
to that
tougher facing magic or bird
i'm gonna go with magic of course i mean
bird is bird man you know he was he is
he's among the all-time greats 10
greatest
ever played a game the way he competed
he was not going to be
friends with anybody he wasn't shaking
anybody's hand before the game
he was he was like bill lambie with more
talent and not as dirty
did he talk trash to you
i tried if he did i was trying not to
listen but he would he would tell you
you know you shouldn't be on me you
can't guard me
take this one with you and knock a shot
down on you but i just tried to ignore
it because there was nothing i could do
about it anyway
so i didn't let it hurt my feelings do
you think your son
is the best shooter in nba history
of course i do of course dell thinks
that steph is
uh bradley beale's father thinks that he
is uh
little i think that he is but yes i mean
obviously clay is in the uh
in the conversation and he should be i i
know there's one thing
um and i told him this and i told other
people it's on
on the record and on the air i think the
warriors when they had kevin durant they
had the three
greatest shooters on the same team in
history i don't see how anybody could
dispute that
uh duran yeah durant's a great shooter
um
it just you you sort of you're wondering
about that didn't you watch him play
with the warriors did you see all those
great shots he was knocking down from
everywhere yeah he's a mid-range jumper
you know
that three he's knocked down to uh to
clinch the finals against
in lebron's face yeah anything i believe
see you
you are in the east coast you're up too
late or whatever so i but i watch every
warriors game with kd
that man is uncanny how well he can
shoot michael michael
michael i've been watching nba games i
remember you in
college so i've i've watched a lot of
basketball
and i i think kevin durant is one of the
you know top
five shooters probably in the history of
the game i was just having a little bit
of fun there that's all
okay you understand little i don't know
that's why i don't know i don't know if
we'll ever see a team
like we saw in the wars with with three
guys i got on the same thing i don't
think we'll ever see that again
i think that steph has done more for the
game than michael jordan did for the
game
boy that's huge to say that i don't know
i mean obviously staff has been the face
of the league for
years but i don't know man michael
jordan arguably the greatest player ever
is either him or kareem
um but look at the impact though steph
has had michael
everybody thinks you know you you have
guys who've come into the league
and they think they can be nobody
thought they could be michael jordan
and what they did yes they did carter
kobe what are you talking about no no no
but they're you know they're they're
more people playing basketball more kids
playing basketball think they can be
steph curry then they can be like
michael jordan would you say that's fair
okay okay okay yeah that's fair so
that's everybody that's an impact
like trey young is in the nba he's a
byproduct of steph curry
yeah yeah but michael jordan is
responsible for cody
kobe even said that so how do you
compare say
guys like trey young wanted to be steph
when you have guys like kobe and dwayne
wade who wanted to be michael
yeah but dwyane wade wasn't michael kobe
was pretty damn close to michael but
there's only a couple of guys there are
more guys who
uh have that ability to shoot deep
because of steph curry
i just think his legacy will be he he
he made it cool for little little
smaller players
to think they could play in the nba that
you didn't have to jump out of the gym
you didn't have to be exceptionally big
and i think that that was
that's steph curry's legacy on this
sport oh that's a great point yeah
because you're right you look at michael
jordan and he was a physical specimen
six foot six
why are you strong you're right not
every kid's gonna be that way but steph
when he came into the league he looked
like he was one of the ball boys
and uh so that's uh that encourages
other kids to say if he can do it i can
do it you're right about that but
imagine if he played against
the celtics back then in the 80s like
what how much would they have just the
pistons bad boy like they would have
roughed him up
right because you could matter doesn't
matter dan
that's a tough competitor just don't let
his pretty boy look and his hands don't
look screw you that man
doesn't back down from anybody and great
players like staff they could play in
any era
i don't care who he's playing against
what are you going to do you can't stop
that though the way he gets his shot off
from that range has nothing to do with
you yeah but you could put your
body you could put your hand on him you
know you could be far more physical so
it'd be harder for him to get to his
spot
you're not giving him credit the way he
can dribble and get around guys seth's
got some of the best ball handling
skills we've ever seen him
him and kyrie irving isaiah thomas tim
hardaway those guys
you can put your hands on them because
of their ball handling abilities they
can get away from you
what if i have you and clay
versus steph and dell people always
asking that question who would win the
curries would kill us
because they don't lift they don't miss
see i would be i would be such a
such a hindrance to clay because i can't
shoot like dell
the dell would go around me he would
knock down threes and then as soon as as
soon as the thompson's missed which i
would do
then the currys would take over if it's
uh
if it's hit or take it uh then they
would they would one they'll
win it's like if they were going to 11
by one it would they blend up nine to
two and play would make the two shots
but if i at your peak at in your prime
and uh and dell in his prime how would
you guys do
then uh going to eleven by one it would
be eleven to 6 because i would miss
and clay would be mad at me it wouldn't
speak to me for weeks because i blew the
game because i can't
i couldn't keep up with dell i know the
curry's adidas i'm not so
i have a big ego but i i admit i'm
humbling enough to admit the courage of
win
oh it's great to catch up with you
michael as always we appreciate your
time thanks for joining us
yeah anytime dallas good to talk to you
never turn down dan the man
thank you michael michael thompson
lakers radio analyst two-time nba champ